like and I talked about this after Mike
got back from India and he had a chance
to go and visit these slums and he said
that you know the best fighters in the
world come out of the slums I came out
of the slums Mike obviously grew up in
one of the toughest parts of Brooklyn
you guys grew up in a really tough part
of Ohio talk a little bit about the
adversity you saw as a kid Cody and you
know how that really molded you into the
fighter that you are not even even
beyond just the physical fighter you
know and having this dream of being in
the UFC but your mindset as a person
because you've got a lot of wisdom in
you and you're not you know you're a
young guy I think that's a contribute to
my mother and the practice that she
taught us and her putting us in sports
at a young age knowing that was a kind
of a way out you know that's something
that I think that she saw with her
brother too that he was good at sports
but he couldn't stay out of the trouble
you know I mean so yeah I think that she
just instilled that discipline and that
hard work and I dedication to you know
show up to practice you know why kids
are out playing you're going to
wrestling camps or and she would I think
that we valued our time with her mom so
much that we realized at a young age
that it was more than just our dreams
you know it's hers and and it was us
together so spend that time her packed
up in the vans driving across the
country to the wrestling matches
national tournaments wrestling camped
you know and just just seeing that it
was real you know a product of our
environment is grow in a positive light
you know because obviously talk about
negative and the upbringing is that we
didn't have you know but we did have
some positive there and I think that's
truly separate us from D another
statistic or stayin put in that town not
reaching our full potential as humans it
was our mother and her drive and her
dedication to make us you know to our
full ability as humans and I'm forever
grateful for the teachings that she gave
to us because she had to be the mother
and the father you know I thought I
wasn't there and you know we had we were
adopted by her ex-husband now but
so our father figure wasn't there so she
had to give us a tough love rule yeah
like my consequences of getting in
trouble was you not a you know the
police action or the school action
suspending you was what my mama's gonna
do that that was she's above every law
yeah I mean like I said she can take it
she brought you in this ro Qing take you
around she meant that [ __ ]
[Music]